i'm on the uh a caffeine high tonight
just like
wow and i thought what a great night to
set some very
ambitious promises
what i want to do today is list all of
the series that i plan to start
start not finish the ones i plan to
start in 2021
just to give you people out there in the
void
some indication of the direction this
channel is edited what do i want to read
what do i feel like reading well
let's get down to the brass tacks look
before i get into all the series i want
to get started on next year
let's wrap up some loose ends mainly the
stormlight archive
and dune so as a priority plan to
complete the dunes series
very soon actually i plan on reading it
plan on reading children of dune next
this bad boy right here and then i have
all the rest of the series back here i
have been
deprived of dune and i really
need to finish this series so that's
that's first on the list
also of course stormlight archive i have
taken
a hiatus somewhat on
oathbringer i do plan on finishing it
but for myself for
this time of year there's a lot of stuff
going on very busy
i had to take a break and just read some
other stuff
for the hell of it i read something
wicked this way comes i've been reading
some jack london and
oathbringer was getting a bit stagnant
so i'm going to finish oathbringer by
early january honestly with winter break
i'll probably finish it over winter
break so i'll probably take a bit of a
break from the series and then read
rhythm ritama rhythm of war
so those are the loose ends first off
that's right that's right i have been so
freaking excited to start malazan i feel
like
it's just the series that most intrigues
me people talk about how
complex it is how huge and vast it is
how interesting
the writing is and then they have andy's
channel where he talks about malazan and
he has such
great videos about malazan and
post-modernism and all that and i'm just
like
yes i need more of that oh my god i love
that [ __ ]
i will definitely be reading gardens of
the moon very soon i'm really excited to
dive into that uh next up this is a book
i
just got off thrift books the dragon
bone chair
which is part of memory sorrow and thorn
heard really good things about
tad williams heard that he's has quite a
way with words
and the covers here are gorgeous i think
that's michael whelan covered yep
michael whelan
cover of this book just gorgeous
enticing i am
so eager i have no idea what it's about
but that's even better
next we have assassin's apprentice
by robin hobb oh that's a note that i
wrote to my wife that's sweet
anyways uh farseer trilogy book one
robin hobb i just hear wonderful things
about robin hobb all
around also has a way with words
and just like malzahan andy talks about
how
amazing robin hobb is so i need to get
on with the
program and just read this series also a
series i have been
really wanting to dive into look i'm a
bit of a slow reader
i like to take my time i like to jump
around now and then but
i definitely want to at least start all
of these series
and that includes the dark tower i heard
that the first book is not the
is probably the weakest part of the
series or one of the weaker
parts of the series i think it was
originally short stories
something like that daniel green's
channel really got me interested
i am very intrigued and excited to
see what happens in this series also a
series i've been meaning to read
for a long time dresden files again
another daniel green
channel find i read the first chapter of
this i think on
amazon or something apparently jim
butcher wrote the the first chapter for
the dresden files in a class he was
trying to write the most
commercial thing he could think of to to
prove that it like wasn't good to his
teacher like he couldn't write that kind
of thing and then he wrote it it was the
first chapter
more or less for storm front and the
teacher was like
you have something here and he went with
it i don't know if that's true
i think i heard that somewhere i watched
jim butcher say that somewhere i could
be totally off but
if that is the case that's [ __ ]
hilarious and
finally a tiny confession um
i haven't i haven't read lord of the
rings that is a
a glaring oversight in my life and i am
sad about it every day
and i feel like if i were to get hit by
a car
tomorrow and die and i mean wherever i
am after i die
with angels or wherever they could very
easily start making fun of me
for not having read a lord of the rings
and i don't want to live with that i
don't want to die with that so
it's a fairly high priority that i need
to read lord of the rings i read the
hobbit
a long time ago and i read the first
half of fellowship
i think like most people i stopped
because i went
oh this is very different from the
hobbit and uh quite slow and i think a
lot of people will admit that yeah the
first half of fellowship is quite slow
but i feel like i am more mature i'm an
adult now
i can and will read lord of the rings
i've seen the movies
well holy mackerel seems like we have a
lot of books to read next year don't it
i have a feeling that 2021 is going to
be a great year for reading
for all of us i hope we have a great you
know what way to wait
wait a second uh
grant i'm reading grant
look i know it's not a [ __ ] series
i'm reading this book because
you know what you people can't tell me
what to do i'm not bound by any rules
you say
jump i say don't tell me what to do
anyways
this is a book we are
almost in 2021 sounds a bit surreal to
say we're in the future man
i remember back in my time you know i'm
not gonna get into it let me know what
your reading plans are in 2021 what do
you what are you
what are you going to read like and
subscribe if you're
oh my goodness that was like just doing
that with my head
you can make me black out for a second i
need to slow down on the caffeine
and yet finals are still going on what a
conflict
thanks for watching